all right what's going on guys this is
rob we are back with spider-verse now
this is the week of thanksgiving so just
so you guys know videos are gonna be
pretty scant this week we're kind of
hammering them out on monday and tuesday
and then my guys get the rest of the
week off normally i would just give them
the whole week but i wanted to kind of
upload some of these or at least record
some of these and we were running a
little short on time last week and over
the course of the weekend so um you'll
have three videos you'll have this one
you'll have a second one on wednesday
we'll have beyond omega level on friday
and then that'll be it um and then next
week we'll pick back up with our regular
scheduled programming so what this does
here is this picks up with earth 98 120
yet another alternate reality here in
marvel comics and this one specifically
focuses on miguel o'hara now one of the
things about this is that this version
of miguel is actually part of the
avengers of this universe and we'll
explain miguel here in a little bit or
at least give a little more detail but
this version of miguel here again as
part of the avengers is basically
experiencing this kind of feeling where
somebody's stalking him right where
somebody's hunting him now here's one of
the big differences between miguel
o'hara and the other spider-man and this
is something that will address as things
go on with spider-verse is that each
time a version of miguel is killed he
feels it right he actually experiences a
kind of dizziness or kind of haziness
that impacts him physically whenever
that happens now this particular miguel
doesn't really seem to experience that
instead you basically have more lun who
shows up on the scene and basically
overpowers the avengers and when i say
overpowers these guys it's no small
thing right like these are some heavy
hitters in marvel comics well heavy
might be a a little over exaggeration
here i mean you got captain america and
you got wolverine that's cool you do
have genus vel this guy is nuts okay
assuming this guy has the same power
that his main marvel universe version
does he's actually a genetically created
version of marvel of the creep but this
guy got so powerful he actually
recreated the universe right this guy's
powers is just it's stupid right he was
so powerful marvel had to kill him off
and then basically replace him with
philavelle of course fly lavelle was
really really really cool she ended up
becoming the new quasar and marvel
comics during the whole dan abner cosmic
era but nonetheless this guy is a
universal force it's basically what
we're getting at here right morlun
overpowers every single one of these
guys like he literally drains genus veil
of his cosmic energy he attacks
wolverine and captain america takes both
those guys out and then in turn kills
miguel o'hara siphons his energy off and
then basically bales now when that
version of miguel o'hara dies miguel
o'hara from the main marvel universe
that's the one who experiences this
whole thing every single time that
happens it almost kind of seems like
he's losing a piece of himself right
it's kind of a mental backlash to a
degree now while this is happening of
course he's currently in the present in
the maine marvel universe it's a whole
story arc involving like tyler stone and
everything from his timeline not overly
important here the fact is that he is
currently here in the present day
there's some villains that are trying to
get away he of course ends up
incapacitating them but the first thing
he comes to the realization of is with
all this going on i need to get a hold
of peter parker right i need to find out
what's going on here and so what he ends
up realizing here is that with
everything going on once these criminals
are basically sorted out at this point
it's on the hunt that caused him to feel
this just kind of giant headache of
what's going on there and so what you
end up doing is that in this moment when
you have more lund that kills that
alternate reality version of miguel
o'hara there's actually a kind of portal
which is more of a viewing screen that
opens that allows miguel o'hara from
earth 6375
to view everything that's happening and
of course he's basically realizing that
morlun and the inheritors are killing
all the different versions of himself
now for those of you guys who are
familiar with marvel comics specifically
in the mid 2000s with exiles issue
number 75 you know who this guy miguel
o'hara is he was part of the exiles for
a long time now for those of you guys
who don't know who the exiles are
they're probably one of the most
underutilized but most interesting
superhero teams in all of marvel comics
these guys basically travel the
multiverse and so you got some stupidly
good stories with the exiles back in the
day the exile stories that i actually
enjoyed the most were the ones that were
basically post house of m the world tour
story arc so you got to see them
traveling to like the future imperfect
universe with maestro hulk you got to
see all kinds of cool stuff right it was
awesome to see them travel the most
popular alternate realities in marvel
comics but they were basically like like
imagine an avengers team on a
multiversal level that was basically the
exiles i'm very very certain we're going
to see them in the future of the mcu
coming out of the events of doctor
strange 2 assuming the multiverse
remains intact but nonetheless this guy
miguel o'hara was part of them now one
of the things he says is that while he
was there with the exiles he did become
aware of morlun and the inheritors but
they never actually crossed paths and a
lot of that was just because of what we
saw when it came to like spider uk right
like the incursions dealing with all
that stuff and the fact that like
saturnine didn't really care about the
fact that maurlen and all the inheritors
were hunting the spider-man from across
the multiverse that the multiverse
itself was actually failing while the
exiles were a big thing in the mid 2000s
and the multiversal collapse had not
actually begun yet there were a lot of
other threats out there the exiles had
to deal with and so the reality is these
different inheritors traveling around
the multiverse and killing spider-man
wasn't the most important thing to the
exiles and honestly they didn't realize
how far-reaching it was it was really
more whispers and murmurs right things
that people were kind of talking about
in these sort of shadowy corners of the
multiverse but nobody really knew that
it was as big as it was but the
inheritors had been killing hundreds if
not thousands of spider-man up to that
point and they've just continued on
during this time right and so as a
result of that with this alternate
reality version of miguel he realizes
that there's so few miguel o'haras left
in the multiverse that his idea is to
basically find as many alternate
versions of himself as he can and then
basically unite them that's an important
thing to grasp here this guy doesn't
know superior spider-man is assembling
an entire spider army he's totally
unaware of that and it makes sense right
if i asked you right now what's going on
in times square like what are people
doing in times square you couldn't give
me an answer because you're not there
you have no idea what's happening out
there unless you have an apartment that
overlooks times square and you're
watching this video then sure you can
give me an answer but outside of that
you wouldn't be able to give me an
answer and that's what we're talking
about right i mean it's one of the
things we've said before the multiverse
is a big place and so it's very very
easy for all kinds of things to happen
out there and for you to have no idea
that any of it's actually happening now
this also seems to indicate that each
one of the miguels were that were killed
had never seen or never been greeted by
the spider army of of superior
spider-man either that or if it did
happen it was after this version of
miguel stopped watching and so
regardless his response this alternate
reality version of miguel is we need to
go to the earth 616 universe we need to
go to the main marvel universe and when
this reality's version of mary jane
watson asks him why are we going there
his response is because it's the one
place that morlun is scared of right
it's basically kind of like a safe haven
he's like maurlen doesn't want to go to
the main marvel universe he's afraid of
being there he's died there before and
every time he goes there he seems to die
so he's just terrified of it the problem
is that main universe is not a permanent
safe space because while maurlen is
afraid to go there his other relatives
are not and so it's only a matter of
time before they show up in that
universe and try to attack that
reality's version of peter parker but at
the end of the day we need to go find
miguel o'hara in the 616 universe
wherever it is that he happens to be and
so what ends up happening here is that
following miguel's story he begins kind
of experiencing again one of these just
giant headaches and then following his
kind of leaving a big meeting and going
onto the rooftop the portal opens up and
when it does you're basically met by the
arrival of morlun that caught up with
spiderman 2099 from earth 63-75 it
killed that alternate reality version of
miguel and when he did of course he
siphoned off his energy basically you
know taking his life force and then
miguel again experiences that massive
headache that basically happens whenever
an alternate reality version of himself
dies and so of course more lung drops
the body but it's one of the funny
things here is that miguel watches all
this happen and while it seems like
moreland is standing there for hours in
reality it's only been a couple seconds
or so but he looks terrified he's afraid
to enter the main marvel universe it
terrifies him because he's just been
killed by peter parker every time he's
come there and so he doesn't actually
enter instead he just stays and then
eventually the portal closes and he
basically walks away but because of this
because of the fact that maine marvel
universe miguel right 616 miguel
witnesses the death of his alternate
reality counterpart that he basically
realizes we've got to find peter parker
now having said that there are a couple
things that i do want to address here
first and foremost this version of
miguel o'hara the main marvel universe
miguel o'hara he is referred to as 616
miguel that's actually not accurate
technically he comes from earth 928
which is in the future earth 2099 was
initially the actual future of the maine
marvel universe until marvel started
abandoning the ideas of guaranteed
futures and in turn turn them into
alternate realities just possible
futures and so that's why you see
stories like marvel 2099 you see days of
future past old man logan they're all
referred to as alternate realities
because while any one of these universes
could actually become the future of
marvel comics we wouldn't really know
until we got to that point and creating
an absolute guaranteed future started to
become a big no-no under joe quesada
right it was one of those things where
make it an alternate reality it's a
possible future that way we're not
locked into having to make sure that
everything that we publish leads into
that future and so the other thing about
this is the reason why miguel has these
headaches is because the alternate
reality version of himself from 6375 had
basically used exile technology across
the multiverse to create a kind of
headband that psychically linked every
single miguel o'hara now it wasn't as
though all the miguels knew of all the
other miguels instead it allowed him to
know where all the miguels were at and
what they were doing but because of the
fact that the headband was linked to the
multiverse it linked all the miguel's to
him using a psychic connection and
that's why the main marvel universe
miguel o'hara would experience those
headaches because he was basically
getting visions of when each version of
himself died it's also the reason why
when that version of miguel with the
headband died the headache that miguel
experienced was worse than any of the
others and so again i felt like that
just kind of needed to be stated here i
know it seemed a little confusing at
first and that was one of the things
that i didn't initially catch on to when
we originally covered spiderverse but i
felt like it was something to sort of
reiterate here so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end i
will see you guys on wednesday with our
next video and yeah
i will catch you all later
peace